[Música]
boa tarde a todos
um adolescente do morro do adeus no
subúrbio de bonsucesso criou um jornal
para ajudar a resolver os problemas da
comunidade
a entrevista emocionante do estudante
renê se o ano de 14 anos deu voz à
comunidade em que vive no rio de janeiro
ele criou um jornal a idéia prosperou em
um jornal já pode ser encontrada em toda
a cidade
clicando basicamente durante a invasão
do complexo do alemão as informações da
favela para fora da comunidade para fora
nem imprensa está ventando durante
aquela guerra que rolou em 2010
quem abasteceu o mundo de informação foi
ele o renê o seu jornal comunitário de
uma voz da comunidade
na verdade é que neste natal a história
de um adolescente de 16 anos que
distribui cestas básicas no conjunto de
favelas do alemão ele já faz isso desde
os 11 anos de idade e que organiza tudo
recolhe as doações e fases já tem que eu
gosto
a segunda para provar que tem que a
curiosidade e o resto que são elas
inveja tava empreendedora também a
chance de sentinela do nada senão eu
quero fazer jornalismo mas eu quero
fazer jornalismo do meu jeito na minha
comunidade eu vou criar continua a deus
aqui no rio de janeiro uma das favelas
que fazem parte do complexo do alemão
onde há um ano aconteceu toda aquela
confusão da ocupação militar e tudo mais
no meio de toda aquela conclusão o rei e
ficava relação do gugu através da
internet
tudo o que aconteceu e é com ele que a
gente vai falar agora
renê bom dia tudo bem com você
com apenas 17 anos rené foi uma
testemunha importante da ocupação do ano
passado o alemão ficou famoso por tuitar
em tempo real conflito entre as forças
armadas e o tráfico
hoje ele tem um jornal ou a voz da
comunidade e é um colaborador importante
dentro do grupo j vocês lembram das
cenas da invasão no complexo do alemão
essas cenas a que dá uma olhada
pois é quando isso aconteceu o menino
que era morador da comunidade na rua
tudo isso pela internet nas redes
sociais e acabou ficando famoso no mundo
todo e nós fizemos questão de trazê lo
aqui na vila gaúcha o rio grande do sul
no porto alegre para que ele conhecesse
a menina que faz mais ou menos a mesma
coisa
senhoras e senhores renê silva então boa
tarde a todos
eu não merecia eu tenho 25 anos fiz
aniversário esta semana 24
obrigado obrigado eu vou compartilhar
hoje com vocês a importância da
comunicação comunitária como vocês
puderam ver não sei quem já ouviu falar
quem já conhece a voz da comunidade
alguém já conhece ouviu falar da cana
boa parte aqui compartilhar agora com
vocês um pouco dessa história de como
comecei nem foi na verdade muito novo
ainda e eu moro no complexo do alemão
não é vizinho ac da unisuam complexo do
alemão que tem cerca de 180 mil
habitantes é uma das maiores favelas do
rio de janeiro
sou morador do morro do adeus que é uma
das três favelas que formam esse
complexo e eu estava na escola municipal
alcide de gasperi
quando eu tinha 11 anos de idade em uma
escola aqui em higienópolis muito perto
daqui também
e existia um projeto criado pelos
próprios alunos pelos professores né
criado pela escola que era do grêmio
estudantil
1 qual os alunos criaram um jornal e uma
rádio escolar e eu fiquei muito
interessado ali motlaq legal jornal
escolar uma rádio da escola mas o que
estão falando sobre o que estão falando
ali e eu fui me informar e o que estavam
falando ali era sobre os problemas
sociais que existiam dentro da escola
como a falta de manutenção da quadra a
falta de material didático a falta de
merenda problemas relacionados à escola
e eu comecei a observar aquilo tudo
pensando caramba que bacana estão
fazendo e também mostravam talentos
mostrava o que tinha de bom dentro
bailarinos dançarinos né pessoas que se
formavam a líder depois de passar pela
escola e eu fiquei muito interessado em
participar àquele jornal
mas eu não podia porque eu tinha 11 anos
de idade eu conversava com o diretor a
conversar com professores ele falava
só quem pode participar são os alunos
que já estão já passando quase para o
ensino médio são os alunos lá das 7ª 8ª
série e você ainda tem 11 anos da 5ª
série c não pode e não mas eu quero
participar tenho muita vontade e tenho
muito interesse e eles falaram assim não
infelizmente não dá agora andar e eu
chegava em casa e ficava olhando nelly
os jornais sempre fui muito curioso
sempre foi muito interessado na leitura
pegava jornais pegava livros ficar
valendo e nunca havia a comunidade ele
olhava nunca olhava complexo do alemão e
quando falava complex alemanha sempre
sobre a violência sempre sobre a guerra
sempre mortes tráfico polícia a operação
invasão e nunca sobre os outros
problemas sociais que a gente vive ali
dentro né então comecei isso aqui que a
gente que eu posso fazer eu posso fazer
eu voltei na escola conversei com a
diretoria e falei com a diretora que
queria participar àquele jornal da
escola que era de verdade meu maior
interesse e que gostaria de criar um
jornal pra dentro da comunidade
a diretora mas você nem entrou no jornal
das caldas e quer criar um jornal para
dentro da comunidade final mas eu tenho
uma vontade eu quero fazer e aí eu
trouxe esse papel aqui justamente para
mostrar isso porque o jornal ele começou
ainda em uma folha de papel ofício assim
dobrada como vocês podem ver e eram
quatro páginas é exatamente isso eram
quatro páginas
eu não conseguia fazer mais do que 50
cópias porque não tinha dinheiro a
escola que ajudava a diretora da escola
os professores lavar pode fazer a cópia
que no primeiro acesso ao computador meu
primeiro acesso à internet foi dentro da
escola ea diretora ajudou todo mundo
ajudou e eu lá como o jornalzinho
pequeno dentro da comunidade
distribuindo e não imaginava onde
pudesse chegar nem o objetivo é só
mostrar o que está acontecendo na
comunidade
só que teve uma grande diferença né
quando o presidente associação de
moradores quando as sombras da
comunidade e eu nos órgãos da prefeitura
do governo reclamar sobre os problemas
da comunidade
este é um diferencial que ele ser um
jornal na mão geralmente todo mundo
chega a falar com o atleta
andré os programas sociais mas aqui no
morro do adeus especificamente um jornal
e quando ele levava o jornal tinha uma
diferença muito grande porque todo mundo
falava de um jornal na comunidade os
moradores criaram que quis então os
problemas começaram a ser resolvidos
muito mais rápidos os problemas que
levavam selar meses para ser resolvido
começaram a ser resolvidos em semanas 15
dias dez dias né da noite pro dia
esperamos começaram a ter uma resolução
muito rápida e muitos talentos muitas
pessoas talentosas da comunidade
começaram também né até uma visibilidade
que através do jornal comecei a mostrar
lhe falando só que eu ainda era como eu
falei eu era muito novo e meu irmão saía
do meu lado renato moura é hoje é o
chefe de redação do blog comunidades
hoje a gente até inverteu os papéis
porque eu estava ali pra câmera
fotográfica ele que é o fotógrafo e eu
com jean e ele com o jornal na mão e eu
era muito pequeno na criança de 11 12
anos naquela coisa toda
então ea avó meus pais todo mundo ficava
muito preocupados assim com aquela
situação
mas você está se expondo muito você é
criança você chega parte das vezes em
casa na escola porque você foi um
acidente de ônibus você e eu muito
curioso e ela tirava foto né pegava e aí
pelo fato de ser criança então isso
atraiu outras crianças a fazer parte do
jornal então a minha redação do jornal
era feita por outras crianças é o
computador ainda que lhe deitar aquela
coisa toda
então outras crianças meu primo entrou
nem meus vizinhos todo mundo entrou e
cada um com seu interesse pessoal né
teve gente que entrou no jornal criança
ainda falou assim ah não quero entrar no
jornal porque eu quero ajudar é a
melhorar o campo de futebol que eu quero
jogar futebol eu quero entrar no jornal
porque eu sei que dá pra conseguir fazer
isso entrou no jornal acabou continuando
cada um tem os seus interesses ali mas a
gente conseguiu ajudar muito a
comunidade resolver problemas como
saneamento básico problemas de ruas
esburacadas falta de iluminação pública
falta d'água os problemas do nosso
cotidiano
e eu comecei a crescer nem aí o jornal
também começou a crescer
eu ali já estava com um de 15 para 16
anos o jornal começou a crescer mas
ainda assim eu ali crescendo com 15 16
anos ainda era muito novo então as
pessoas não acreditavam que era o que
fazia um comerciante local da comunidade
não acreditava as pessoas que eu buscava
apoio e no sesc e não isso aí aquidabã
ao redor do bairro aqui do alemão e as
pessoas não acreditavam porque eu era
muito pequeno sempre achava assim a não
tem algum político por trás tem alguma
associação de moradores têm uma ong
então as pessoas ficaram muito
preocupados e já não tem alguém por trás
dele não é possível que ele esteja
fazendo sozinho e eu fui lá criei
algumas estratégias comecei a colocar
foto minha no jornal segurando o jornal
querey estratégias pra conseguir fazer
com que os comerciantes anunciassem o
jornal né porque muita gente falava se a
não sei vou te pagar aqui não sei se
daqui o mesmo jornal quando sair vai
estar lá meu anúncio prova não vai ficar
assim e eu comecei a criar algumas
estratégias fazer para fazer com que os
comerciantes permanecessem né e aí eu
fui conversei com o comerciante eu
lembro que na nova brasília mercadão
brasília carlos cheguei lá por seu
manoel olha eu quero colocar um anúncio
de vocês aqui talvez vá mas vai no
jornal vai sair mesmo não vai não vai
sair foi tão beleza falei daqui a 30
dias tome paga depois que o jornal sair
e eu fui criando essa credibilidade essa
confiança dos comerciantes e os
comerciantes né foram acreditando é isso
jornal foi aumentando cada vez mais
e aí eu tive acesso mais ainda a
tecnologia como tinha falado lá em 2005
quando eu comecei com o jornal eu tinha
acesso a ele o computador primeira vez
mas ainda não tinha tablet eu não tinha
computador em casa usava da vizinha net
uma vizinha lá patrícia ela tinha era
uma das poucas da minha rua que seu
computador então usava o computador dela
até conseguir comprar o meu na época em
48 vezes aquela história toda
mas eu tive acesso ali já internet e em
eu criei uma conta é no twitter
só que muita
a gente usava o twitter ainda quase
ninguém usava o twitter praticamente né
eu criei uma conta lá e deixei morta lá
não usava mais é muita gente né já
estava começando a migrar do orkut para
o facebook estava começando aquelas
migrações das redes sociais de ms n né
vai começar aquilo tudo e eu aproveitei
que tinha criado a minha conta crie uma
conta pro voz das comunidades também é
quando eu comecei a criar conta do voz
eu pensei sim poxa eu posso falar que
também sobre os problemas sociais que eu
já falo no jornal impresso e de repente
vai ter um impacto maior na internet e
de repente vai ter um alcance maior
e aí criei só que não dava dando ainda
muita gente um lembra que o twitter do
voz tinham 300 seguidores a minha conta
tinha umas 500 pessoas mas era um é
amigos da escola professores eram
pessoas ligadas a mim ou que tinham
visto alguma reportagem
e aí né eu comprei meu computador que eu
tinha falado em 48 vezes conseguir
parcelar ele o notebook e e aí eu com a
gabi renato
aqui a gabi renato a gente foi crescendo
aquelas crianças né daquela foto deu
nós fomos crescendo e cada vez mais
pensando como a gente podia ainda ajudar
mais ainda nossa comunidade com a gente
podia mudar essa realidade diz o jornal
foi crescendo é o número de exemplares
que eu falei que era um 50 cópias e 2010
a gente já estava com 5 mil exemplares
a gente foi cada vez pensando era preto
e branco foi pra colorido né a gente
falava de poucos problemas sociais a
gente aumentou é a nossa editoria
começamos a falar de programas sociais e
empreendedorismo dentro da comunidade de
perfis de moda então a gente abriu o
leque das editorias e aí finalmente em
2010 aconteceu o grande boom aconteceu
ali a ocupação do complexo do alemão
onde todo mundo ficou sabendo no mundo
acompanhando né essas imagens todas essa
principalmente que foi transmitida pela
globo então brasil o mundo inteiro
acompanhando isso e eu como tinha falado
que tinha conta no twitter
mas pouco usada nem um centavo
muita valia no twitter e aí eu fui
peguei e entrei no meu twitter para
saber o que estava rolando no meu
twitter pessoal ainda e aí eu vi que
estava muita gente falando ocupação do
alemão aquela história toda ocupação mas
eu não tava falando nada e eu comecei a
falar até na ocupação aqui a operação e
tal e aí muita gente perguntando você
está bem você está seguro você está em
casa onde você tá que tá acontecendo e
respondendo também o seguro dentro de
casa protegida estava respondendo e as
pessoas mandavam mensagens e aí de
repente dessas dimensões que estou
respondendo dos meus amigos
de repente apareceu assim tipo 900 novas
menções ao 900 novas menções eu tenho
400 seguidores como ao centro às novas
dimensões e de repente mil novas
dimensões 1.200 2000 não pagaram
milhares de pessoas vêm mencionando e
não sabia nem o que estava acontecendo
até porque eu tinha pouquíssimas
seguidores
eu fui tentar descobrir o que estava
acontecendo e eu descobri que os meus
amigos né que estavam perguntando se eu
estava bem estava seguro estava em casa
eles começaram a mandar várias mensagens
para pessoas famosas neoci novo
apareceram no vídeo ele foi um dos que é
recebeu a mensagem falou ó segue esse
menino aí que ele mora lá no alemão
aí a preta gil recebeu a mensagem glória
perez então sim meus amigos ali o meu
ciclo eles começaram a mandar várias
mensagens para pessoas famosas dizendo
que estava ali dentro da comunidade e eu
comecei responder começava a esconder e
esses foram alguns dos tweets na época
estava respondendo e aí quando eu
atualizei a meu twitter eu já tinha mais
de 10 mil seguidores e muita gente ficou
preocupada com aqui todo mundo conseguiu
deus que se quer outra fazendo eu lembro
que recebeu a mensagem na época de um
dos diretores da tv globo e zeland ele
falou menino pelo amor de deus tira sua
localização os bandidos ou a polícia vai
saber onde você está pelo amor de deus
para de falar pelo seu twitter
o frei não mas eu talvez não pelo amor
de deus para de falar pelo seu twitter
entra na conta do jornal que talvez as
pessoas vão dá uma credibilidade
diferente por ser um jornal da
comunidade e sai do seu twitter e eu
fiquei meio
nada naquele momento eu falei tá bom vou
sair do meu twitter eu entrei pelo
twitter do voz da comunidade
quando entrei pelo voz da comunidade eu
tava com os 150 180 seguidores já tinha
mais de 15 mil pessoas seguindo nem
falei que ia sair do meu ia pro todo
mundo foi pra lá e aí quando as pessoas
começaram a seguir voz da comunidade
muitos famosos começaram a falar também
glória perez e renata ceribelli hugo
gloss tico santa cruz todo mundo
acompanhando aquele momento e falando e
aí teve uma repercussão né internacional
até muitos jornais muitas revistas e eu
não imaginava que isto pudesse acontecer
porque eu tô ali na internet está na
internet não sabendo de nada
inclusive a minha família não estava
sabendo de nada né minha mãe por exemplo
ela estava assistindo televisão quando
de repente se na globonews aparece uma
reportagem falando e agora o menino
morador do complexo do alemão está
publicando em tempo real tudo que está
acontecendo aí minha mãe você sai do
computador desesperar sabe o computador
agora desliga isso pelo amor de deus eu
fui não mas não falou nada demais não
sai daí você não sabe do risco está
correto foi tudo bem tá bom é isso aí
e aí de repente a repórter lá voltou bom
parece que as coisas acalmaram pelo
alemão porque a gente não tem mais
nenhuma informação do que está
acontecendo lá através do twitter do voz
da comunidade
eu falei tá vendo preciso voltar a
escrever o quinto voltar a escrever aí
falou tá bom vai com calma pode voltar a
escrever mas vai com calma e eu voltei a
escrever no dia seguinte quando eu fui
acordado num acordo foi acordado tipo 7
horas da manhã estavam vários
jornalistas várias pessoas no meu portão
eu não passei endereço pra ninguém não
sabia de nada quando cheguei lá todas as
emissoras do brasil nego globo recopa de
tv brasil sbt e emissoras internacionais
porque é óbvio que ficam vários
correspondentes aqui no rio então tinha
al jazira cnn bbc e pessoal no meu
portão querendo saber de mim eu ali com
17 anos qual foi o planejamento pra
fazer um tuitaço da operação do complexo
do alemão foi bom não teve e não tem mão
um planejamento e eu ali com 17 anos
perguntaram mas
você que faz você estava por trás
daquela conta porque estava todo mundo
acompanhando aquele momento lá você é
você que tá por trás daquela conta tipo
17 anos muito novo
então falei assim só eu prazer
regressiva
ela é obrigada
[Aplausos]